the so-called world shortest railway
will reopen to the public this morning
in Los Angeles the Train known as Angels
Flight has carried people on and off for
much of the past 116 years it travels
around 300 feet on a 33 degree incline
in the heart of downtown LA but on many
occasions throughout its long history it
almost disappeared for good CBS Sunday
mornings Lee Cowan shows us the
decades-long effort to save this
pop-culture icon the site of a herd of
goats in downtown Los Angeles
sure was a head scratcher but their
appetite had purpose they were here to
clear the underbrush on an incline too
steep for any lawn mow a hill too steep
for just about anything in fact save the
little engine that could in 1901 the
angels flight railway began what would
be over 100 million trips up and down
LA's Bunker Hill from top to bottom 300
feet the world's shortest franchise
railway yes it was short but the commute
was practical in the morning or in the
afternoon people would be commuting to
and from their work Gordon Pattinson
remembers his first ride as a child in
1946 for him the twin cars named all of
it and Sinai are every bit as iconic as
the Hollywood sign itself because it's
have the same absolutely the same
that ring of the cable over the rollers
that's what I remember he became a piece
of pop-culture making frequent cameos no
problem
Perry Mason boarded angels slide for a
trip to the courthouse far below
[Music]
it was an extra behind Jimmy Stewart in
the Glenn Miller story here we go and
it's currently the scene of the crime in
the upcoming season of Amazon's
streaming series Bosh as in detective
Harry Bosch I always be the guy who
killed somebody on Angel's life
best-selling author Michael Connelly
says angels fights place in la Loire
made it the perfect setting for his
famed gumshoe to search for clues to me
Angelus late is a real live metaphor
it's it's a bridge that goes from old LA
to new LA this little railway even won
an Oscar with some help from Emma Stone
and Ryan Gosling they're on board kiss
in la-la land
was no accident Gosling told the story
that when he was an up-and-coming actor
he was living downtown about a block
away from angel slate and he always
wanted to ride it and it was always
closed yes like any Tinseltown tighten
its career had its ups and downs by the
late 60s progress in the form of
downtown skyscrapers had made angels
flights seem more like a relic than a
railway in 1969 it was dismantled and
put in storage there was such a hue and
cry from the citizenry it was loved that
much it was love that much by the people
of Los Angeles and the City Council on
behalf of the people made the promise
it'll come back it took almost 30 years
but angels flight did finally come back
but there was a problem
the restoration had been done improperly
in 2001 one of the cars broke loose
killing an 83 year old tourist it was
shut down then in 2013 a derailment
forced yet another shutdown and that's
where all of it in sign I have been
sitting ever since there are only
customers those goats knowing the
growing grass beneath that could have
been the end of it yeah and then should
we just sort of give up and walk away
and we all look to each other said we
can't do that but angel sleight needed a
few angels to foot the bill for a return
to service
they came in the form of downtown
investors anxious to weed the old into
the new a host of safety upgrades have
been done
they even evicted the termites and
finally angels flight is now back on
track Gordon Patterson is just waiting
for the paint to dry it's still here and
so am I never gets old for you don't it
gets old the old-fashioned feeling of
going nowhere fast maybe that's a sign
of progress too for CBS this morning we
count Los Angeles brings that romantic
mystique back to LA that's a commute for
me though yeah